The difference between our reaction
after the New Zealand was condemnation.
I do condemn that. Everyone condemning
it. After the terror attacks, we can
hear from imams.
What the hell is he talking about? Which
Imam, Muslim spokesperson or social
media like myself have ever come and
said,
I'm so happy to be able to talk to
[music] you today. And mashallah my
brother our sheh Ali Hammuda is doing a
great job. Work forever is a very very
uh beautiful cause because the reward of
what you give is not just at the moment
of giving but rather it is prolonged for
a very very long time [music] and it
lasts for as long as that work continues
to generate to generate some form
[music] of benefit. So I highly
recommend walk forever as an ambassador
of Abdullah Aid. I know the the uh
partnership that we have is amazing
[music] and uh not many people
understand the concept of wak yet the
reward is far greater through the wak.
[music] So inshallah if you can support
walk forever uh it will be really really
amazing and very very rewarding.
To brothers and sisters and dear
friends, hope you guys are well in I
came across this video. It's a little
bit old, but I found it quite profound
because it shows the hypocrisy and the
double standards of certain individuals.
This is Mahi Hassan and Mati Hassan
where he needs to be praised, we praise
him, which is when it comes to these
dialogues and debates. There's a lot to
learn from him. This is the Polish
president who is saying that the reason
why the crime rates in Poland are low is
because they don't take Muslim
immigrants. Interesting. Okay, no
problem. Let's use this logic against
him. So we're going to watch a video of
Meth Assan speaking to him inshallah and
let's see what we can take from that.
>> Christian culture, Roman law, Greek
philosophers, these are the the virtues
for us.
>> It's funny that you mention It's funny
that you mentioned Can I jump in a
second?
>> Sharia law in Europe.
>> Okay.
>> I am I am I am the member. Let me
finish.
>> Having Muslims in your country doesn't
mean you have Sharia law. You mentioned
London. The mayor of London is a Muslim.
There's no Sharia law. Let me ask you
this. You mentioned London. Some would
say it's hypocritical that you don't
want Muslims in Poland because let me
finish places where the shar is.
>> Let me finish a question. Let me finish
the question. Many would say it's
hypocritical. Uh that you say you don't
want Muslim immigrants in your country
because they commit crimes. There's a
security threat. And yet you hear
exactly the same rhetoric about Polish
immigrants in the UK from right-wing
politicians and media there. They say
the polls are groping women. They're
feckless. They're criminals. They won't
integrate. Don't you see the irony or
the hypocrisy of treating Muslim
immigrants to Poland in the same way
that some that some Britain treat Polish
immigrants?
>> Okay, good. This is this Let's just stop
here for a second. Okay, so number one,
um, of course, let's be honest with you.
Here uh the Polish uh or the Western
immigrants, they do um uh fit in uh
better in the Western world. Why? Uh
because you know their culture is very
similar. Drink alcohol, go partying,
have a hedonistic lifestyle, me me
selfish, etc. uh when it comes to uh
rape cases, when it comes to these other
things, uh which is a result of alcohol.
Um and alcohol is a major play in this.
When it comes to the NHS, yes, uh a lot
of Polish people, I mean, I'll be honest
with you, I know myself cuz my dad used
to be a wholesale alcohol seller. I used
to actually work with them. I used to
deliver this to shops where Polish
shops, I can remember like and so many
of them drink alcohol like it was like
for them it was like a juice. It's like
me drinking orange juice. And that has a
ripple effect of domestic abuse in the
house. Yes. That causes like for example
many other things because when you're
under the influence you can do all kind
of crimes. Be it drink driving, be it
getting into an accident, be it causing
liver disease, kidney disease, heart
disease, one of the biggest issues that
affect the NHS. So they assimilate
really well and they come with all those
other problems that the Brits have cuz
they have the both the same problem.
Hedenism, self selfishness and also the
uh habit of drinking alcohol. So the
thing is here is though we want to see
if this man is going to be principled
and have not double standards. Let's
carry on.
>> Okay. How many polls blow themselves up
in London or any other place in the
world? That's the question I keep
repeating.
>> There is a lot of crime carried out by
Polish immigrants according to the right
killing themselves and others because of
their religion. Dominic Dominic, your
argument doesn't work. Just last month
in the UK
[laughter]
specific I'm answering your question.
How many how many of them blowed
themselves up? Okay, let me answer your
question.
>> So, okay, interesting. Me is going to
answer this, but the question he's
asking is very simple. I mean, I can
answer that and say zero. Zero Polish
people have blown theirel up. Okay, what
is your point? So, are you saying that
the only way somebody's life is taken
unjustly by lunatics is done by
fundamentalists going out there and
blowing theirel up? No. cuz number one
you're generalizing all because that's a
very small fragment of groups uh who
define theself as Muslims who are
extremists just like Christians just
like Jews just like Hindus extremists
they exist everywhere it's not that that
argument there is not exclusive to Islam
Christian fundamentalists in central uh
Africa have done this the New Zealand
attack that happens that killed 51
Muslims there the mass shootings that
happened on a weekly basis what happens
by radical Zionist in uh Palestine these
are all things so it's not exclusive to
Muslims And your argument that the only
way that people lose their life is by
individuals doing these terrorist
attacks is not true because people lose
their lives with many gang violence etc.
So many of they all should be
categorized wrong. Well, let's see what
methan say in this way. A Polish
immigrant was charged with the rape and
murder of a British student last month.
How would you feel if people in the UK
started saying we don't want polls here
anymore, we don't want rapists and
murderers here. That's what you say
about Muslims. You generalize about all
Muslims in the same way that some on the
right in the UK generalize about polls.
There's a lot of anti-Polish racism in
the UK. Do you not see the irony that
you're doing the same thing to Muslims
as is done to polls?
>> Let's see. Okay. I'm really intrigued to
hear his response. Okay. Let's see. Is
he going to consider say you know what?
Yeah, I was wrong. Let's see.
>> No. No.
>> Okay. All right. No. Okay. I'm sure he's
going to justify. I'm sure he's going to
say, you know what, here is the
difference between the two.
>> First of all, if someone if anyone
committing a crime should be jailed, it
doesn't matter. as a Polish as a as a
English or anyone else.
>> Really? You must be joking. If somebody
commits a crime, what should they be do?
Be locked up. H interesting. I think a
terrorist attack is also a crime. They
should be locked up. H you're making
sense now. Are you what? Absolute
muppet.
>> That's number one. Crimes which you
mentioned are not committed in the name
of Allah.
>> What's that got to do? Talk about
security. Who cares?
>> They are just criminals. We're talking
about security but why not?
>> So, so what makes it okay? What is it?
So, if you do it in the name of
something makes it worse. If a crime is
done, if one individual goes and says I
am going to kill someone because
argument sake my religion tells me to,
which is not true. Okay. The other one
says, I'm going to go and take the life
of someone because I'm angry. I'm angry
at the world. And somebody comes and
says, I'm going to go and take the life
of someone because of this person
upsetting me or whatever. They all are
taking the life of an innocent soul,
regardless of in the name of this or in
the name of that. If someone's drinking
alcohol and that clouds their judgment
and they do something that causes
someone to die, it doesn't matter if it
was intentional or not. You went and
killed somebody. It doesn't matter if it
was in the name of alcohol, in the name
of Allah, in the name of Jesus, in the
name of Yahoo, whatever it is for that
matter, a death is a death.
>> Number one,
>> why not generalize? Why not why
shouldn't British people generalize
about polls? You're generalizing about
Muslims. Not all Muslims are terrorists
as you know.
>> But all terrorist but all most
terrorists are Muslims.
>> So I can say the same thing. Yes. Not
all pedophiles look like the Polish
president. But for some reason all
pedophiles look like the Polish
president. Okay. So not every single
pedophile is a white middle-aged man
like the Polish president. But for some
odd reason all of the pedophiles are
like a white middle-aged man like the
Polish president. Do you see where the
argument becomes stupid?
That's not true. As you know, in fact,
that's not actually true. The most of
the farright terrorist attacks were from
Christian. They committed a crime. They
should be
>> It's funny you say most terrorists are
Muslim. This year, one of the worst
terrorist attacks that we saw was in New
Zealand. Christians carried out mostly
nonbelievers.
>> Okay. So, he's saying that Christians
don't carry out um attacks against
non-believers. Yes, they do. If you look
at anti-semitism, where does it come
from? It comes from the crusaders. In
the infidel, the word infidel has been
ascribed to Muslims. We don't even use
that terminology. Infidel is from the
crusaders. Why? because they would go
and persecute the Jews because they
killed their god Jesus. And that's where
it comes from. So the non-believers
thing was a very pro prominent thing.
That's why the the the bishops and the
priests gave the go-ahead ahead to the
crusaders. Yes. The pope you blessed
them and said the holy war etc against
the infidels and so much so crusaders
would they would ransack and massacre.
Not only that there was even
cannibalism. They would eat the flesh of
the Muslims and the Christians that they
have massacred in history. One of the
worst terrorist attacks this year, one
of the most high-profile was the murder
of more than 50 Muslims in New Zealand
by a Christian far-right white
supremacist.
Yeah. And he's jailed.
>> Oh, okay. All right. Okay. He's jailed.
Okay. All right. He's jailed. Okay. Why
doesn't the same apply to a Muslim?
>> So, so, so what? So, Muslims are jailed
as well. What's your point? Should I
blame all white Christians for what that
man in New Zealand did? My point is that
the the difference between our reaction
after the New Zealand was condemnation.
I do condemn that. Everyone condemning
it. After the terror attacks, we can
hear from imams.
[applause]
That's the reaction. What the hell is he
talking about? Which imam or any Muslim
spokesperson or social media influencer
like myself have ever come and said
when when has anyone ever said that? the
contrary what's happening in Gaza you
see all the western leaders nearly all
of them who are saying what excuses not
condemning it if anything that's why
they say every accusation is a
confession if anything the western world
has been silent if not complicit of
what's happening in Gaza you know why
because they have dehumanized those
people so every accusation is a
confession because did you come out and
condemn Benjamin Netanyahu no you didn't
you even invited him if I'm not mistaken
to your country my friend you're a
hypocrite as you know and they want to
kill all the infidels so that's a lie
[laughter] dominating between western
civilization
>> I imams across the world do not applaud
terrorist
>> attacks you can just Google it just
Google it
>> okay you can google also the Charlie
Hebdo attack okay you say this is this
is a lie to say all news I can tell
>> okay let me ask you this question you've
got you've got hate preachers hate
preachers means
>> that's not all imams though you said all
imams clapping let me ask you this
Dominic After the Charlie Hebdo attacks,
you had the king of Jordan.
>> There you go. You don't have hate
preachers in the Christian churches.
This guy is out of his mind. You don't
have hate preachers in Christian
churches. Are you okay? If you go to
America, these Zionist Christians,
Judo-Christian values, whatever,
oxymoron, do they condemn what's
happening in Gaza? No, they don't. They
actively support it and say that has to
be genuine Christians have come and
condemned them and said, "How could you
say this?" Like Candace Owens. Yes. And
many of them have come out and said,
"What are you on about? I'm a Christian.
I'm not going to allow this to happen.
This is wrong." Nearly all go Christian
Bible belt. Okay. In in in in America,
they all say what? Yep. They're sharp.
There the holy lands and the holy lands
can do holy things, unholy things
otherwise. So there you go. Do you talk
about that? No, that's not true either.
After the Charlie Hebdo attacks, you had
the king of Jordan, the prime minister
of Turkey, the foreign minister of
Egypt, the president of the Palestinian
Authority, numerous leaders from the
Muslim majority world literally march
through the streets of Paris in
solidarity with the non-Muslim victims
of those attacks. I don't remember
seeing you or any other member of the
Polish government marching in Christ
Church, New Zealand in solidarity with
the Muslim victims.
>> And not only that, did they march when
it come to the Gaza situation? Nope,
they didn't. Did they come together and
condemn it? Nope, they didn't.
>> It's solidarity. I don't remember seeing
you marching in Christ Church.
>> All this solidarity, all this solidarity
candles and all this painting on the
floor. It's it's a joke.
>> But where was you need this kind of
>> What's a comeback? All this solidarity
is a joke. What an intellectual
comeback. Dominic, your arguments are
falling like dominoes. One by one.
>> Your march. I don't remember seeing your
march in New Zealand action.
>> Dominic, I don't remember seeing you and
the Polish government marching in New
Zealand. Answer that. Why didn't you do
what Muslim leaders did? Because we
behave differently in Christ Church.
>> We don't need marches. We have our
borders.
>> One second. You behave differently.
Okay. If you are better than those
Islamic terrorists that you're talking
about, then why don't you behave
differently? They these Islamic
terrorist fundamentalists which we our
religion condemns are targeting innocent
people and the whole world condemns it.
What about the bombs that been dropped
in Gaza like nuclear like a nuclear
weapon? 60 to 70 80,000 people have been
massacred. Why are you not coming and
saying we behave differently? Why are
you not behaving differently? Rather
you're supporting it. Rather you're
supporting it.
Every accusation is a confession. You
guys are the most corrupt double-standed
hypocrites. The western world mask has
dropped and the entire world sees it.
The way America's behaving, the whole
world can see it. You guys are no damn
different to those terrorists that you
condemn. Are safe? That's got nothing to
do with the question. A Christian
farright nationalist carried out an
attack in New Zealand. If you're saying
Muslims should condemn a Muslim attack,
which they did, why didn't you go to New
Zealand and condemn that attack? Why
didn't you march like Muslim leaders did
in Paris? Why didn't you march in Christ
Church?
If you think that these Muslims, these
preachers, these imams are so peaceful,
let them go to Saudi Arabia. Let them go
to Qatar. If you want to be a refugee,
you have to flee to the first safe
country, neighbor country. Then you have
to apply. You have to prove who you are.
And now we are having people in Europe
which is not which is Poland is not a
neighbor of Syria without documents or
with five passports the same picture and
different names. That's just a fact from
our interior ministers. So it's all
about safety. You are trying to put the
whole subject in a box of Muslim
Islamophobia.
Even even if if no believer will going
to come or Buddhist we will not let him
in if he's illegal. That's it.
>> I mean look I have to be just and fair
here. Nobody's saying you should open
borders to anyone. I believe it's not
Islamophobia that you check who this
person is, what they're doing, and if
they can uh come and you know, if
they're not criminals. I don't have an
issue with that. Subh. And if you look
at it, for example, if we look at some
uh articles here, let's go to some news
articles here. Okay, this is very
interesting. Okay, look, some of them
look I just look even um I was just
reading it. It says what?
Polish nationals are a significant
foreign nationality in the UK's prisons,
often ranking second or third in
numbers, involving in various crimes
from firearm smuggling to modern slavery
with concerns raised about criminal
records sharing and deportation
processes though many face offenses
stemming from social issues like
exploitation. UK authorities track
foreign national offenders and while
Polish nationals commit serious crimes,
some cases involve exploitation rings
where poles themselves are victims.
Okay, good. Okay, that's one thing. So
if we go to one, so for example, we have
one here from National Crime Agency.
Yes, if we go to that, it says Polish
National jails for smuggling 61
firearms. Yes. Two uh firearms, firearms
in the UK. Here's another one. Poland's
most wanted. Poland's top 10 criminals
on the run in the UK. Can you imagine?
The top 10 wanted individuals are in the
UK just running around. The Polish mafia
is turning the UK turning the UK into a
hot bed of mob violence as scores of
dangerous gangsters flood here to escape
justice back home. Detectives say an
alarming number of dieh hard criminals
have fled to soft touch uh to soft touch
Britain taking advantage of our lacks
border controls. Murders, drug dealers,
and kidnappers are among them among more
than 3,000 fugitives who have escaped
prosecution by hiding amid our teeming
Polish communities. Warsaw's top cop
this week launches an appeal through the
Sun on Sunday to ask our leaders to help
them find the vile suspects. Detectives
handed over their dossier on the
thousands they believe have fled here,
including their top 10 most wanted men,
the most dangerous men in Poland are in
the UK, kidnapping, killing, murder that
can offend. And not only that, rape and
many other stuff. Okay? Do we come and
say this is a Polish issue? Do we come
and say they should all be condemned?
No. because we say it's a criminal
that's doing a criminal behavior that
should be jailed. Okay, this includes a
mafia godfather, fraudsters, rapists,
murderers, drug dealers, and heavily
armed gangsters charged with a string
string of crimes back home. Our police
are also concerned about the rise of
Polish mafia in the Britain. They
recently established an office in the
former communist block country to help
them stem the tide of organized
criminals. Okay, so it goes on and on
and on. So what do you say to that?
Okay, and I just want to end on that
note, guys. There's nothing else that
needs to be said. Uh I think we can play
in if there's anything else that mass
would like to add.
>> Go back to my question which you avoided
answering. The Christ Church shooter was
an immigrant. He was a Christian. He was
a white nationalist who killed Muslims
and he had on his weaponry references to
a battle in which a king of Poland
defeated Muslim invaders. He had the
name of a Polish military commander on
one of his weapons. So I ask again, why
didn't you, according to your own logic,
go to Christ Church and disown him? say,
"This has nothing to do with us. Nothing
to do with Poland or Christianity."
That's what you expect of Muslims. Why
didn't you do that in New Zealand? I ask
again.
>> Well, thank you very much. Thank God for
King Subies. He stopped Muslims in
Vienna. Thank God for what the terrorist
said as well, by the way. But I'm not
going to react on any idiot who is
trying to use our king and beautiful
history for a terror attack.
>> And why can't Muslims say the same? Do
you not see the illogic of your
position? You're basically saying what
every Muslim says about Muslim terrorist
attack.
>> Invited them. Not not at all.
>> He just praised a king that this New
Zealand attacker wrote on his machine
gun and he's just saying, "Yes, praise
praise him." And the terrorists done the
same thing by quoting him. You can't can
you imagine a Muslim ruler praising
saying a a a ISIS terrorist doing an act
writing the name of let's say a ruler
who did an atrocity against Christians
and he writes it on his machine gun and
and the Saudi Arab or whoever it is like
let's say Muslim president or a leader
ruler comes and says yeah praise that
person they will be uproar absolute
uproar but you can see the stand guys
there's nothing else needs to be
inshallah subhan allah put him in his
place once again and you can you see the
double standards and hypocrisy of these
western leaders being shown. That's all
I want to do in sisters. Till next time.
Hope you guys enjoyed the video.